Depending on your
RStudio Cloud pricing plan,
you may have access to the ability to tune
your project resources. To access project
resources we'll need to be within a project
or an assignment on RStudio Cloud.
From here, we can click on the settings
icon at the top of our project
and navigate to the resources tab.
From here, we can change
the amount of memory allocation,
CPU allocation, and/or the background
execution limit.
RStudio Cloud's pricing is calculated
based on project hours,
and not project run time. As such,
note that changing our memory allocation
and/or changing our CPU allocation
will change the project hours
consumed by the project,
based on one hour of project runtime.